un autre de mes ancêtres reçu dans son
château
la visite du roi louis xiv et puis et
puis il faut pas oublier il y avait la
baronne albertine du sne homme qu'était
la confidente de la reine catherine de
médicis savez-vous tout ça je viens
faire mon arbre généalogique que c'est
passionnant
vous vous êtes monté dans un arbre
monsieur doucement cela m'aurait étonné
fayon casimir faire son arbre
généalogique sait faire la liste de ses
ancêtres
ah oui je comprends alors vous êtes
descendus de l'arbre comme message
c'était pour entendre monsieur ne veut
prêter votre regard quasi vierge
en bas il y a le nom de la personne qui
désire connaître son arbre généalogique
ici au dessus dans les 2 15 cette
personne mais le nom de son papa et de
sa maman
comme ces deux personnes légalement et
atteignent maintenant cela fait quatre
cases pour les grands-parents et comme
ceci aussi est atteint et bien cela fait
huit cases bossu pour les arrières droit
par marie gillain quand j'ai compris oui
mais alors combien faudrait-il de cases
pour remonter jusqu'à mon ancêtre
casimir premier il ya 5 millions
d'années sa queue est mûr je n'ai aucune
idée
bonjour tout le monde je n'ai pas à
monsieur du snob
j'ai une lettre pour moi qu'elle
favorise encore écarté moi ou pour rien
alors laisse moi lire je te prie
pardonnez moi mes amis
[Musique]
voyons cela
oh mes amis je suis invitée au bal que
donne la comtesse de bellefeuille
mais pourquoi n'at vite auriez-vous pas
julie j'aurais tellement plaisir d'aller
un val malheureusement chers amis ce
ballet réservé aux gens de vieilles
vieille noblesse à aa
ça ne m'étonne pas que veux tu insinues
et casimir écouter du mur coûté à
garçons attendez moi une seconde vous
allez comprendre la machine à explorer
le temps est trop court sur une réserve
une surprise
voilà grâce à ma machine à explorer le
temps j'ai découvert des choses
étonnantes
je vous propose donc de venir avec moi
un jour de l'an xiv 183 attention départ
en route pour le départ
[Musique]
approche maintenant monseigneur emile
l'archevêque bateau lire l'acte
d'accusation
monseigneur
nous amy archevêque de lille aux enfants
accusons le masne ans note d'avoir voulu
faire précéder son nom de la particule
du afin de se faire appeler du snop
usurpant ainsi un titre de noblesse ne
savais tu points maintenant que tu
insultes et ainsi les grands de notre
île
rabon aux ensembles lieu du tout porté
par chez nous un succès tout genre
fleurs de navets ou betteraves à gorée
home on voit tant de naïveté ne peut
vous a cité qu'à un verdict de clémence
je ne peux rien vous refusez princesse
du lit tu sera coupée en deux et du lot
bonnes décisions et ses alliances
j'aurais pas venu on ne commente pas les
décisions du grand roi casimir tu seras
couper en quatre une quattro un centre
des décisions
monseigneur émis cesser de tout commenté
relatait cela m'agace et votre majesté
me pardonne moins n'était pas oui tu
sera coupé en oui à jour une brave de
penser moi on était à quatre il dit vrai
hautmont roi et dans votre grande bonté
ne pourriez vous pas adoucir encore un
peu sa peine mais enfin en cas trop ce
n'est pas excessif
or aux jeux jouets mes prières à celle
de la doule ce pcs julie soyez magnanime
roi casimir la postérité vous en sera
gré aussi les troubadours se mêle de
rendre la justice maintenant où allons
nous bon tout sera coupée en deux n'ont
pas
abbas survient content mais sans vouloir
vous déranger peut pas faire encore un
petit effort aux deux la clémence la
postérité bon terminons cette affaire à
monseigneur prenez note à
là maintenant ce noble aura le droit de
porter le titre ii du snob à condition
qu'il n'oublie jamais qu'il doit cette
faveur à la bonté du grand du bon du
généreux roi casimir 8230 quatrième du
nom voilà vous cache t se plie et vous
le portrait au conseil de l'illustré roi
je ne suis pas facteur je suis
archevêque rome et c'est vrai pour sûr
où avais je la tête
[Musique]
un archevêque une tresse la troubadours
en oublie par un ancêtre de kazimiya je
ne me ferais jamais avait pourtant tout
cela et pichot ricard inès ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est des snobs
c'est pourquoi cette duchesse de
bellefeuille vous envoyer une invitation
il n'y a peut-être pas tellement de
mystère là dessous n'est ce pas que du
snowboard
que veux tu dire kazimi alala casimir
qui nous doit une explication rue et je
veux dire comme ceux du snav n'a pas plu
à emmener julie aubert pour la bonne et
simple raison qu'il n'y avait pas de
balle
pas plus que d'un contest de
bellefeuille à j'ai vu ce matin monsieur
du snob qui se postaient cette lettre à
lui-même au
jg